it was a dark day in lebanon's history
august 4 2020 a massive explosion at
beirut port tore through nearby
neighborhoods killing more than 200
people injuring thousands hundreds of
thousands were made homeless
and it all came without warning two
years on there's still been no
accountability for one of the biggest
non-nuclear blasts in history not one
top official has been held to account
even though the investigation has showed
that a range of officials politicians
heads of security agencies even judges
they were all aware of the presence of
highly explosive material ammonium
nitrate at one of the warehouses at
beirut port so families of the victims
are still fighting for justice even
though many will tell you that they've
lost hope in a country with a culture of
impunity in a country where the
political class has come together to
stand in the way of any accountability
political crimes have gone unpunished in
lebanon
the political class has managed to block
the investigation in fact it has been
suspended for months politicians wanted
in connection with the blast accused of
criminal negligence have filed lawsuits
against the lead judge in the case
taught it better and better really has
come under a lot of pressure from the
different political parties accusing him
of bias so he has not really been able
able to work even the arrest warrants
that he has issued have not been
implemented by the security agency so
he's really up against a political class
which is refusing accountability it's
not just accountability
there's still no answers people are
demanding answers on why was the
ammonium nitrate at beirut port in the
first place who owned this ammonium
nitrate did that ship make an
unscheduled stop to beirut or is any
political party involved in bringing in
that flavourable material so it's not
just the question of justice and
accountability people also want answers
the blast really is symptomatic of
everything that is wrong in lebanon
corruption in state institutions
negligence on the part of the
authorities the failure of the state to
protect its citizens the blast happened
at the time when the country has all but
collapsed the economy all all but
collapsed because of decades of
mismanagement and corruption so people
are not really surprised on how the
authorities have dealt with the case
especially after the blast they said
that the investigation will be completed
in two to three days and there will be
justice two years on no accountability
no justice and no answers